I want you to imagine no social media at
all no internet no phones emails text no
mass media but Islam was still spreading
to the different corners of the world
how you might ask because the Sahaba the
companions of Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam they
traveled the world to share this message
of tawheed la ilaha illallah muhammad
rasool allah there is nothing nothing no
one worthy of any act of worship except
the creator of the heavens and earth
Allah and Muhammad like Abraham Moses
Jesus but he was the final messenger
sent as a mercy to mankind imagine just
imagine how arduous of a task that was
on horseback Wow we have trains planes
and luxury automobiles you got to ask
yourself the question why did they do
this Dawa because they knew what was the
best job brothers and sisters the job of
all the prophets and the messengers the
best of mankind because they understood
this Deen this way of life the best they
understood the important applications
and the tremendous rewards of dollar and
the ramifications if they didn't answer
the call of God Almighty Allah by now
you're probably thinking how can i how
can I get in on all the tremendous
rewards probably asking yourself that's
a great intelligent brilliant question
ask did you know that there is a hadith
that talks about even those who help
prepare the saddles of those horses that
those Sahaba rode on who went out
struggling in the cause of the Almighty
getting this message out those people
who supported them will get similar to
equal reward did you know that now you
know now now is your chance to help
prepare the saddle to support those who
are struggling to
the message with the world now if you
didn't know already the DS show is one
of the first and only Islamic TV talk
shows in America since 2006 having
produced over 600 episodes of
hamdulillah delivering the message of
tawheed sharing the purpose of life
clearing the misconceptions and removing
the doubts about Islam and if you didn't
know Islamophobia is also on the rise
it's an industry that brings in over 250
million dollars of year doing the work
of Shaitaan spreading misinformation and
lies about Islam you gotta ask yourself
another question why are the people who
are spreading lies hate and fear about
Muslims in Islam more organized and
supported brothers and sisters by being
silent doing nothing not supporting
those who are struggling to get the
truth out
are you not complicit the question is
will you be of those who help prepare
the saddle and gain in on all the
tremendous rewards by supporting the D
show
helping us deliver this message of
tawheed clearing the many misconceptions
sharing the purpose of life with the
world what are you gonna do now